wenn du diese kleinen Fliegen an deinen
Pflanzen entdeckst ist es Zeit
einzuschreiten warum weil ihre lfen eine
Vorliebe für frische Pflanzenwurzeln
haben und was passiert wenn die Wurzeln
angeknabbert werden ganz genau deine
Pflanzen gehen kaputt wir müssen also
dringend etwas unternehmen aber was die
meisten Leute bringen diese Gelbtafeln
an ihren Töpfen an und lassen es dabei
beruhen aber das ist ein großer Fehler
die fangen nämlich nur die Männchen ein
die weiblichen Trauermücken die fleißig
eierlegerinnen die dafür sorgen dass
umso mehr lfen entstehen flattern aber
munter weiter wir müssen also etwas tun
um den Kreislauf zu durchbrechen als
erstes aber ein Tipp um vorzubeugen dass
sich die kleinen Störenfriede überhaupt
bei dir breit machen können meistens
schleppt man sich Trauermücken über die
ansuchterde ein deswegen ist es gut wenn
du die Erde vor der Aussat im Backofen
sterilisierst der maulwurfskuchen ist
fertig aber wahrscheinlich hast du ja
schon Trauermücken an deinen Pflanzen
sonst wärst du nicht hier also was
können wir machen um deine grünen
Freunde zu retten die Antwort liegt in
einem winzigen Helfer Nematoden diese
mikroskopisch kleinen Würmer sind wahre
Superhelden im Kampf gegen Trauermücken
lafen und wie machen wir diese kleinen
tapferen heldeneinsatzbereit wir packen
sie mit in unser Gießwasser bevor wir
die Nematoden über das Gießwasser
ausbringen ist es aber wichtig dass du
die Erde einmal richtig schön
anfeuchtest und auch nachdem du die
Nematoden ausgebracht hast sollte die
Erde über zwei Wochen lang dauerhaft
feucht bleiben nicht nass aber feucht
damit die Kleinen Nematoden ihre Mission
überhaupt erfüllen können die Nematoden
kümmern sich also um die ganzen larfen
die schon da sind aber am besten
Unternehmen wir jetzt noch etwas dafür
dass nicht noch weitere Eier abgelegt
werden können und dafür bestreuen wir
die Erde einmal mit Sand relativ dick
ruhig so fast einen Zentimeter dick
warum das weil die Trauermücken es
lieben ihre Eier in feuchter Erde
abzulegen und der Sand sie super
erfolgreich von dieser Erde abblockt und
am effektivsten ist es wenn ihr dann
noch eine dünne Schicht Backpulver auf
eurem Sand ausstreut wieso das weil das
die Trauermücken die noch übrig bleiben
sofort tötet wenn sie damit in Berührung
kommen es dauert jetzt noch ungefähr
zwei bis drei Wochen bis ihr Ruhe habt
vor den Trauermücken aber in der
Jungpflanzenanzucht kann ja noch viel
mehr schiefgehen wenn ihr schon mal so
schwächliche und kränkliche Pflanzen
hattet dann habt ihr vielleicht einen
von den Fehlern gemacht die ich hier in
diesem links verlinkten Video vorstelle
also schaut gerne da drüben vorbei
ansonsten geht raus und macht die Welt
ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns im
nächsten Video wieder bis dann tschüss